so the first and most important thing
you want to do when you're factoring is
you want to look for the greatest common
factor so this is something that you can
divide out of all the terms and that's
the first step you're going to want to
do that that's going to make all the
numbers smaller it's going to make it
easier to go ahead and factor using some
of the other techniques because the
numbers are going to be smaller so once
you factor out the greatest common
factor if it does have one it might not
have one then you have to ask yourself
does the polynomial have two terms three
terms four terms or maybe even more so
if it has two terms it could be a
difference of two squares okay so you
can see a squared minus B squared so
perfect square minus a perfect square or
it could be a difference or sum of two
cubes so you have to see if they're both
perfect cubes either added together or
subtracted okay and then we have a
formula for factoring those or does it
have four terms okay in that case you
would want to try factoring by grouping
so grouping you're going to be putting
parentheses around the first two terms
and the last two terms I'll be showing
you examples of all these different
techniques and then if there's three
terms you want to ask yourself is the
leading coefficient one the number in
front of the x squared is it one or is
it something other than one and you can
see here I've written this as as a and
the technique I'm going to be showing
you is how to split the middle term and
then go ahead and factor by grouping so
you'll have four terms at that point so
let's go through the different types go
ahead and pause the video if you want to
try it on your own and then you know see
if you did it right or if you need to
repeat the video go ahead and do so so
let's start off with the first type the
greatest common factor so I've written
some down here so let's try this first
one 5x squared plus 10x plus 20 so we've
got 5x squared plus 10x plus 20 okay so
the terms are separated by plus or minus
so you can see this is a three terms
trinomial and it looks like all the
terms are divisible by five so what
we're going to do is you can do this you
can actually go ahead and draw a
division bar okay a fraction sign and
divide them all by five
and you can see you're going to be left
with x squared plus 2x plus 4 but what
happens to that 5 is that it's going to
be here in front of the parentheses so
it's like doing the distributive
property backwards if you want to check
your work all you have to do is just
shoot the 5 back into the parentheses
okay and you're going to get back to the
original polynomial that we started with
5x squared plus 10x plus 20
okay let's look at another example let's
do the next one here let's do 6x cubed
minus 2x y squared okay so now for this
example this is a binomial two terms
separated by this subtraction sign okay
the two groups
what can you divide out of both of these
terms well it looks like with the 6 and
the 2 those are both divisible by 2 okay
and it looks like there is one X in
common so we can divide out an X out of
both these groups and it looks like
that's all that we have in common so
what we're going to do is we're going to
divide and we've got 3 x squared - ok
the twos cancel the x's cancel we're
left with Y squared and now what happens
to the 2x that's going to come out in
front of the parentheses ok like so and
if you distribute back in if you
distribute the 2x back into the
parentheses using the distributive
property you're gonna get back the
original polynomial that we started with
so that's the first step in factoring
you know you don't want to forget that
sometimes students will skip over the
greatest common factor they'll want to
get right into some of the other
techniques depending on how many terms
there are well if you do this first it's
going to make your work easier as you go
on in the the factoring process but you
want to factoring is like reducing
fractions you keep reducing reducing
reducing well the fact when you keep
factoring factoring factoring until you
can't factor any further so let's get
into the next type of factoring so I'm
just going to erase this real quick here
for us ok the next type of factoring is
looking at how many terms do you have
two terms three terms or four terms so
looks let's look at some examples where
you have two terms so I've wrote down
some examples for us let's look at
this one here are x squared minus 100
okay so what we want to ask ourselves
okay it has two terms you can see it's
the terms are separated by the minus
sign but is it a difference of two
squares is it a difference of two cubes
or is it a sum of two cubes well you can
see x squared is a perfect square and a
hundred is also perfect square plus ten
times ten so what we're going to do this
is a difference of two squares you can
see a squared minus B squared it factors
as a plus B times a minus B so in this
case our a value is the square root of x
squared which is X our B value is 10
because the square root of 100 is 10 and
we're gonna make one of these plus and
one of them - it doesn't matter the
order you could pick make this - in this
+ now if you want to check your work all
you have to do is foil these together so
you could distribute the X and then
distribute the 10 and you're going to
get back the original x squared minus
100 the reason is is 10 X and negative
10x those cancel out that's why we don't
have a middle term let's look at another
example of two terms let's look at this
one 4y squared minus 100 okay now
remember with factoring most important
step is the greatest common factor so I
want to do that first is there anything
that we can divide out of both of these
terms that's right we can divide out a
four so we're going to factor out the
four and then we're gonna look at what's
left and say can we factor that further
well you can see this is a difference of
two perfect squares
okay difference of two squares so we
factor that as a plus B a minus B so
that's going to be y plus five okay
because the square root 25 is 5 square
root of Y squared is y and y minus 5
sometimes this is called a sum and
difference pattern what happens to the 4
you just bring that down in front so the
idea is if you were to multiply all
these groups together you're going to
get back to the original polynomial you
can go ahead and do that just to make
sure you did the right the right
factoring okay so that's working with
difference of two squares let's see if
we can look at difference in sum of two
cubes now
I'll show you some examples for for
those remember you always want to check
for the greatest common factor first but
let's do this one X cubed minus 8 okay
so the first thing you want to do is
check for the greatest common factor it
doesn't look like there's anything that
we can divide out of both of these terms
and we can see there's two terms so it
either has to be a difference of two
squares or difference of two cubes or
sum of two cubes or it could be neither
but it looks like this is a difference
of two cubes because 8 is 2 cubed and
you can see X is cubed and we're
subtracting so we've got a difference of
two cubes and you can see here I
combined these formulas together but
when you're adding two cubes you add
subtract and add when you subtract your
cubes you subtract add and add some
students they'll remember the acronym
soap you can think of as same opposite
always positive so same meaning if
you're adding you add then it's the
opposite for the second okay sign and
then the last one is always positive so
let's look at this one here so here you
can see X is a + 2 is B okay in this
formula here so what we're gonna do it's
X minus 2x squared plus 2x plus 2
squared which is 4 and we can't factor
this any further so we're done let's
look at another example let's do this
one here 2x cubed minus 54 let's do plus
54 so here again the first step is is
there a greatest common factor that we
can factor out if so do that first looks
like both of these terms are divisible
by two okay so we're gonna do is going
to factor out the two we've got X cubed
+ 54 divided by 2 is 27 and then you ask
yourself can we factor it further
well 27 is a perfect cube it's 3 cubed
and acts as a perfect cube but it's X
cubed so I'm just rewriting this okay
just in a different form so now we can
see alright it's the sum of two
so let's go ahead and use our sum of two
cubes formula and so we're going to do
that now so this is going to be X plus
three it's the same sign because we're
adding you're adding x squared minus the
opposite sign a times B which is 3 times
X plus 3 squared 3 squared is 3 times 3
9 and the only other thing you have to
do is bring down the 2 if you multiply
all these together you're going to get
back the original 2x cubed plus 54 okay
so that's working with when you have two
terms it can be a difference of two
squares or a difference of two cubes or
sum of two cubes there isn't a sum of
two squares at this level of factoring
where you're working with real numbers
ok so then the next one we want to talk
about is factoring by grouping okay so
what is factoring by grouping well I'll
show you so when you have four terms you
want to try this technique and again
remember the terms are separated by
adding okay or subtracting by plus or
minus so say for example we want to
factor this one right here X cubed minus
two x squared minus four X plus eight
okay so notice you have one two three
four groups separated by minus or plus
and we want to factor by grouping we're
going to try that technique because we
have four terms okay so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to group
the first two and subtractions like
adding the opposite so I'm just going to
do that and I'm going to group the last
two okay then what we're gonna do is
we're going to factor out the greatest
common factor out of this group and out
of this group so it looks like we can
factor out an x squared out of both of
these terms so we have X minus two and
it looks like we can factor out a
negative four out of both of these terms
so we're left with X minus two now what
we have we have two groups we have this
group when we have this group notice how
they both have an X minus two see this X
minus two in both groups what we're
gonna do now is we're going to factor
out the X minus two as a greatest common
factor a second time right
we're going to factor that out so it's
like it's like dividing this group by X
minus 2 it's like dividing this group by
X minus 2 when you do that these are
going to cancel you're gonna be left
with x squared these are gonna cancel
you're gonna be left with minus 4 what
happens to the X minus 2 that all that
comes out in front like so so if you
were to take this X minus 2 distribute
it to the x squared you'd get back this
group and if you take the X minus 2 as a
whole and distribute to the negative 4
you'd get back this group here okay now
factoring is one of those things that
you have to keep seeing if you can
factor further okay you want to see if
you can keep breaking it down further
look what we have here we have a
difference of two squares okay so we're
back to here and we're going to use our
sum and difference patterns so this is
going to be factored 2x plus 2 and X
minus 2 and then we're going to bring
down the X minus 2 we can combine these
since we have two X minus 2's into X
minus 2 squared and so there's going to
be your final factored form so this is
factoring by grouping when you have four
terms okay so now let's talk about when
you have three terms okay so three terms
so let me show you an example for this
one the erase make a little room for us
here now there's two different types
here with the three terms okay there's
the type where you have a leading
coefficient of one okay see one in front
of the x squared and then there's a type
where you have something other than one
like a two or negative three something
like that like an a value other than one
so we're gonna look at both these types
let's look at this one first this one's
a little bit easier when leading
coefficients one in the example I've
written down here for us is x squared
plus 7x plus 12 okay so you can see
three terms
now when the leading coefficient C it's
one you just ask yourself what two
numbers multiply to this last term
positive 12 okay I'm sorry I made a
mistake
and they multiply the last term 12 okay
but they add to the middle term seven
okay I just want to make sure I said
that right so multiply to 12 but add to
seven okay so well that's very easy we
just say hmm
could be 1 in 12 2 times 6 3 times 4 3
times 4 is 12 3 plus 4 is 7 so those are
the ones we want 3 & 4 and again you can
check your work by distributing and then
distributing the 3 as well and you'll
get back the original ok because you can
see 3x + 4 X is 7 X ok
3 times 4 gives you back to 12 and the x
times X gives you x squared so again
just remember what multiplies to 12 but
adds to the middle coefficient 7 let's
do another example like that so you can
see say we have this one x squared minus
5x minus 24 okay you can see it's a
trinomial three terms what two numbers
multiply to negative 24 but they add to
negative 5 well it's a good question we
know one of them has to be positive one
has to be negative when you multiply
them to get negative 24
so we'll do plus and minus and we could
do 1 times 24 2 times 12 3 times 8 4
times 6 but you can see this is going to
be 3 & 8 okay because 3 X and negative
8x add up to our middle term negative 5
X now again you want to see if you can
factor further okay but in this case
this is as far as we can go so this is
the fully factored form you also want to
see if there's something you factor out
first okay the greatest common factor
but in this case there wasn't something
that we could divide out of all the
terms so we went right into factoring
when you have three terms leading
coefficient of one okay let's get into
the other type of trinomial that we want
to factor and that's where the leading
coefficient something other than one now
sometimes no matter how much you try
okay or how much you want to be able to
factor something it just might not be
able to be factored and in that case
they call they call it prime okay just
like a prime number like if you have the
number 7 you know it's only divisible by
one in itself and it's the same thing
with with these sometimes you just can't
factor them they're considered prime so
let's look at some examples here I've
written down two for us we've got 6x
squared minus 11x minus 10
okay so what we're gonna do in this
problem here is first thing you look to
see if there was a greatest common
factor doesn't look like there's
anything can divide out of all three
terms okay we know it's three terms and
we know the leading coefficient
something other than one so what we're
going to do is we're going to split the
middle term and then we're gonna factor
by grouping so here's the technique
you're gonna take the leading
coefficient times the constant so we're
gonna take six times negative ten okay
which comes out to negative 60 and then
we're going to solve this problem here
we're gonna say what two numbers
multiply to negative 60 but they add to
the middle coefficient negative 11 okay
do you follow so we want to say what two
numbers multiply to the product of the
leading coefficient and the constant
negative 60 but they have to add to the
middle coefficient negative 11 well
there's a lot of possibilities you could
do 1 times negative 60 or 2 times
negative 30 but it looks like for this
example it's going to be negative 15 and
positive 4 because negative 15 plus 4 is
negative 11 and negative 15 times 4 is
negative 60 we're gonna use these two
numbers to help us split the middle term
into two groups we're gonna write it as
negative 15 X and positive 4x we're
gonna bring down the negative 10 and
we're gonna bring down the 6 x squared
now some students will ask me this all
the time to say does it matter if I put
negative 15 X here or here you know it's
a matter of the order and the order
doesn't matter the main thing is you can
see that negative 15 X and positive 4 X
add up to that middle term negative 11x
so we haven't changed a problem we've
just divided it into two separate groups
so what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna go to the 1 2 3 4 4 terms
we're going to try factoring by grouping
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna group these like so we're going to
group these like so we're gonna factor
out the greatest common factor which in
this case is 3x and here the greatest
common factor is 2
and if all goes well you can see that we
have a 2x minus 5 we have the same
quantity here in common between this
group and this group so we're going to
factor out the 2x minus 5 okay as if we
were doing the distributive property
backwards right we're dividing out the
2x minus 5 and so what we're going to be
left with okay is 3x plus 2 okay this
part can be a little bit confusing
sometimes for students but imagine if
you're dividing this by 2x minus 5 what
are you left with 3x if you divide this
by 2x minus 5 you're left with 2 that 2x
minus 5 doesn't go away it's just you're
dividing it out you're factoring it out
if you were to take this as a whole
distribute it to 3x you'd be left with
this first group here if you take the 2x
minus 5 distribute it this whole group
to the 2 you'd be left with that group
there now you want to check to see if
you can factor it further but it looks
like this is as far as we're gonna be
able to factor this okay it doesn't look
like there's anything else that can be
done so it's completely factored let's
look at one more example like that and
then we'll just kind of conclude this
video this is a beginner to Munich
intermediate level there's more advanced
types of problems that we can factor but
if you can master these steps here
you'll be you know well positioned to do
the other the other steps the more
advanced steps as you get to them so
let's look at this last problem here
we've got 10 x squared 10 x squared
minus 3x minus 4 okay so we see it's a
trinomial three terms we see if there is
a greatest common factor that's the
first step but there isn't we can see
the leading coefficient something other
than one so we're going to look at
splitting the middle term and factoring
by grouping so first step is to multiply
10 times negative 4 so we say what two
numbers multiply to negative 40 but they
have to add to negative 3 okay so what
would that be multiplied to negative 40
the product of the leading coefficient
and the constant but they have to add to
the middle coefficient which is negative
3
well we could do one and negative 42 a
negative 24 and negative 10 we go
through the different combinations but
they also have to at the same time add
to negative 3 so for this one it's going
to be negative 8 and positive 5 that
multiplies to negative 40 but adds to
negative 3 and that helps us to split
this middle term into negative 8x plus
5x ok so if see how those add up to the
middle term negative 3x we're going to
bring down the 10x squared we're going
to bring down the minus 4 now you can
see we have one two three four terms
again the terms are separated by minus
or plus we have four terms that's when
we do the factoring by grouping okay so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna group
the first two by putting parentheses
around them we're gonna group the last
two okay now this isn't factored because
see how there's a plus sign in between
the two it's not like this times this
equals this these are added so what
we're gonna do is going to factor out
the greatest common factor here it looks
like we can factor out a 2x so all I did
was divide this by 2x which leaves us 5x
I divide this by 2x which leaves us
negative for this one there's not a
greatest common factor so really you
could write this as plus one
you're just factoring out one one times
anything is itself right now you can see
there's a 5x minus four in both groups
we're gonna factor out or divide out
that 5x minus four and so what we have
is 5x minus four times 2x plus one
okay just again really quick so if you
divide this by 5 X minus 4 you're left
with 2x if you divide this by 5 X minus
4 you're left with one you can check
your work if you distribute the 5x minus
4 as a whole as a group to the 2x you
get back this term if you distribute
this all to one you get back this term
so you can check to see if you can
factor any further but it looks like
that's as far as we can take this one so